how much energy does it require to get
that [ __ ] done because it seems like you
mean it's just exhausting to get spec I
got sick I was so I got so tired I got
sick like I was hospitalized during in I
was remember I called in I'd remember
yeah like so soon my voice was like gone
and uh yeah it was such hard work that I
got sick when I was flying back and
forth I was like I did the garden I was
like going you know yeah it was too much
I'd bronchitis fractured my own ribs
are you saying do you realize this time
slow down a little bit
yeah yeah I'll never work hard again you
shouldn't never again you had your error
you don't have to do anything yeah
you're worth stands for itself now and
you're done I admit it so you enjoying
it at least what like why perspective
the fact that is coming out and you got
it done and yeah yes and I I'm I think
it's really good and it's really funny
and and it's fun now because like people
are going to see it right okay all this
stuff is actually leading up to people
hopefully see is that why you decided to
do the Barbie movie because you were
attached to the Barbie movie right yeah
no it was just that was like they needed
to start shooting I think by like June
or something and I was like I can't I'll
die doing that yeah did you want to do
it or was it when you see the script was
a decent script um I I was gonna my
sister now we're developing the script
that was that existed and and we liked
what we wrote you know I were like into
it and like it seems like playing Barbie
would have come with an enormous bag of
[ __ ] and like you know being like
famous two kids seems awful yeah who you
are okay that's just our Channel
oh god yeah oh my god
five dollars No